two weeks ago I had a mini breakdown
with my girlfriends but like really it
what was that like what where was it
where did it happen um did
call no it was it was a
intentional meeting per se of of friends
of like we're going to get together and
kind of you know work through our [__]
and be there for each other in a moment
like kind you know just with a lot of
intention and love and
um but without any expectation of kind
of what it's going to be and uh it
turned out being a moment where I really
realized that I needed to have a mental
breakdown I had been holding in and
holding things together for so long and
you know so I have MS and I've had it
for 23 years almost and for much of my
journey I've been applauded and
celebrated for how strong I am
with it and I appreciate that and I can
also appreciate it about myself like how
I've dealt with it but I also think it's
been to a fault sometimes
because a lot of my being strong was
just kind of not expressing how hard it
is sometimes and being like I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay I'm okay no wor it's fine
it's fine and it it was a moment of like
it bubbling over and just I needed to
kind of say all the things that I was
afraid to say which is this sucks and
I'm angry and I'm upset when you say
mental breakdown I think I
think yelling and screaming and
emotional and I can't [__] no I can't
you know like just to the point where
everyone's just like oh we should you
know restrain her or something that's
exactly what it was and I've never had
one in my life I in that Mo I realized
that like even as a a child like I
expressing those
emotions my parents were never able to
receive that they were not in a place in
their lives to allow me to do that so I
was always the good girl I was always
told to you know put on your lipstick
and say everything's fine so that was
the first time that I've really I mean I
think I've had like little eruptions
here and there but to that extent never
and you never done this in front of your
husband I mean he's probably seen me
tantrum for a moment but he hasn't seen
you over the edge no and and it was
actually to a point
where it was bubbling over in our
relationship because he has a lot of
anger for what I deal with because he
has a front row seat every day and I'm
not a complainer I don't say anything
but he sees me grit my teeth and he sees
me push through and on one hand he's
proud of me but on other hand he hates
it like he hates does he get emotional
about it at all not emotional
but I think it manifests in ways for him
like it makes his anxiety worse